tra tutti a ritenere che beppe notizie
di test
oggi nuovo video epico andiamo a unire
come si mangia cosa l'ho tolto perché
adesso facciamo una torta con questa
embra vuoto ma riaffaccia la colla
trasparente qua riesce a vedere la tela
e allora andiamo venire tutti i pigmenti
a tutti andiamo dire anche tutti i
glitter allo slide trasparente domanda
sì perché a solarino uscirà mai persone
noi del piccolo riuscirà anzi produrre
indovinare provate indovinare anche voi
nei commenti scrivete ora non barate ho
guardate il video puoi aprire domanda
aiaf domanda possiamo fare io faccio il
mio lato tocca il cuore poi dopo lo
mischiamo contemporanea così facciamo la
forma
ok dobbiamo chiudere ha solo 13 giu
anche di segnare quando finale che color
diventerà unendo tutti questi colori mi
spiano casi secondo te in gas galassini
che colore grazie vero nero quindi
secondo te nero nero violo galaxy
colorato dottori nota di colore
ovvero nero viola da a neo viola nero
viola cioè vero che dà sul viola ma come
per telefonare in sei bar arcobaleno
così potremo se questi colore 9 con un
arcobaleno tesoro colore grigio grigio
galaxia metallizzato fatto decide mai
allora scrivete voi nei commenti secondo
voi di che colore uscirà scrive però
adesso è quindi un poi chi è indovinata
allora li abbiamo contatti sono 47
quindi abbiamo 46 colori diversi bug
yacht.it irpinia ma non vedo l'ora di
iniziare quindi mettetevi comodi
lasciate un bel like su questo video se
volete vi siano altre cose magari a
questa volta possiamo stare tutti i
colori mentre 60 prendo di pop corn e
posso dire il patto tra loro vita certo
donna cioccolato torrone al cioccolato
con la mia storia
si fa quindi proveremo a fare dei
disegni nel lo slime trasparente che
sembra che non c'è da iniziato scegli un
colore ma dobbiamo mettere tutti tanto e
allora io comincio con cominciamo con
questo che la mia fi
io faccio voglio fare delle sfumature
quindi questa è la terra ferma
costruire un paesaggio non lo so ci
provo
ok allora proprio anch'io costruire un
paesaggio il pratino pure in cielo il
cielo che stare terrance è la pratica il
cielo ok allora i soul qua
ok io faccio una strada che passa qua
vicino al partito
sembra perché devi portare a portare le
persone a questo posto bellissimo parte
poi cosa facciamo le montagne le
montagne un questi glik nel marroni ti
piace la mia ma io volevo fare un albero
lì è libero 6 a fianco ecco la mia
montagna è la montagna con il nero
perché unito hanno già rubato a tig
menti resi meno in nero è il tronco
dell'altro me lo ha mica si compone solo
da un colore che compone da tanti colori
il tronco dell'alba
ora però sono tutto anno sono stato un
impegno troppo diverse non va bene è il
più povero di select e abbiamo stato
l'alberello riusato da tre verdi be lo
facciamo un po di gelo anche facciamo un
cielo multi stagione no che sto dicendo
perché cioè non solo facciamo un attimo
più blu così almeno vabbè anche di notte
e poi mettiamo pure la luna magari ha
pure poi dopo che abbiamo finito i
disegni possiamo ricoprirlo di un altro
colore e iniziarne un'altra registrate
quest'anno suo primo disegno si capisce
di un paesaggio ma dai è bellissimo io
lo vedo allora c'è il sole il cielo
l'album tronco dell'albero con le foglie
la montagna alla strada e tutto il prato
verde ue ci manca solo un gatto una
pecorella quindi il colpevole e passiamo
al prossimo disegno allora vediamo un po
cosa stai facendo questo spargendo se
già tipo si è fatto tipo una superficie
spessa di glitter pigmenti un disegno o
fatto dall'esterno messo un po di
galassia nera
beh ovviamente non può mancare
poi faccio toglierlo da sé non è
credibile non attaccata la co queste
mani la galassia ci vuole ovviamente un
po di blu mettiamo anche dino galati
questa illudeva per il fiore ragazzi
mettiamo anche un po di kit car
questo qui come si chiama un no questo
sia chiavelli po di fuori sia per far
varare e guarda mamma mia che artista
sono un'artista prove ovviamente non è
vero proviamo se mi voglio tanto viola
ma se stelle della galassia c'è anche un
po di diritto questo è canna di fucile
bianco per le stelle ancora chiuso e per
bello team orzelli sembra un pianeta c'è
una galassia se ce l'avete proprio un po
di violetto questo pigmento bellissimo e
qualche stella quella e non tanto lustro
qualcuno è diventato un mix un caos
abbiamo ancora perché descrivono anche
qui tutti questi glik e mostrati a una
strada di al compare lo facciamo i vari
tratti allora rosa a dc celeste oa ma
dove c'è anche il rosso non c'è il prof
ma ci mettiamo quello che vogliamo ma
vogliamo noi
poi questo pigmento rosa permettono
arrivo questi tanto verde proprio per
questo è verde acqua i pigmenti che ci
mette un po di pippetto violetto
pigmento mio letto per violetti picco
arcobaleno bella cosa facciamo loro
diamo anche conoscevano rimasti rosso
rosa rosso pronti gianni bianco il verde
lo abbiamo consumato tutto stranamente
non è per forza finora aldo d'ora poi io
colore bianco qui
e questi tutte le sembrano le spese lo
zafferano impegni cosa disegniamo ma lo
sai che non lo so io adesso comincio
mettendo presto a caso così un degno
libero un disegno libero se ok vediamo
di malti il caso del progetto comunque
super divertente
poi sono curioso di sapere che coloro
riuscirà alla pena vediamo chi ha
indovinato nero o viola metalli stata
più che bello questo
super bowl ha ricoperto di no ma questo
lo smart di natale e cavani con quella
della fame a sesso diventa tutte le
rimostrante da fare come quando colori
io non vedo l'ora di mettermi tutti
troppo contento che ne abbiamo messi
proprio adesso sia attivato solo
praticamente diventato rischio altissimo
quattro colori rosa
questo è uno specializzando dorato
curcuma che cosa che mi manca di
colorina ultimo all'ultimo oro all
ultimo colore di tutti coloro che allora
li abbiamo messi tutti se un mix di
colori incredibile se uno strato molto
spesso è ora andiamo mischiati tutti
vediamo di che colore diventa e poi
andiamo ad attivarmi
o che mai la mano guardate un po come si
muovono wow bellissimi come brillano
fighissimo si muovono tutti come sotto
sono già mischiate tutti i colori ma è
bellissimo veramente sicura dolori nuovo
fratesi lato sta no tipo alcuni ditte
stanno cadendo si stanno abbattendo che
allora io cioè troppo bello vedere tanti
colori incredibile bellissimi ora sta
cimentando tipo giallo devono detto che
dimettere o questa setac al giallo nero
violetto
che bello sembra un quadro quanti questo
è uno sly in tanti colori fichi io
bello davvero mi piace melody mischiano
tutto proprio adesso voglia di girarlo
tutto patto bossi sta diventando marrone
ma te l'avevo detto che sta diventando
il giallo mi sembra
meno ocra pronto non vedo l'ora di
vederlo attivo
wow marroni marrone galaxy tra l'altro
ma non sembra marrone ma mi sveglio
color bronzo metallizzato di crema al
cioccolato tipo lo so penso che per cibo
dove però ha un sacco di riflessi guarda
che vino sempre rudere l'amaranto note
ma ora andiamo ad attivarlo e vediamo
come diventa troppo curioso primo
frullatore giocatore metri di questi btp
archiviano
[Applauso]
panetta caspita devo dire che si terra
questa con la coppia fame eccolo qua
allora il colore e non si capisce una
sorta di bronzo e multi color comparare
le tristi così è un po marroncino
effettivamente e sul morbido nonostante
ci abbiamo messo un sacco di roba
guardate e metallizzato bellissimo e poi
i glitter si sono di tutti i colori su
booking quindi chi aveva scritto
marroncino beige marrone ha indovinato
il bellissimo perché se quel
metallizzato guardate
un sacco di strutture e stavano pensando
proviamo ad aggiungere un commento
e mou se riusciamo a far cambiare un po
il colore viviamo perché la mole di
viola dove aiuto z varrone ero io ho
detto io del progetto neo viola ovvero
allora proviamo aggiungere questo tipo
si usava allora così che possiamo
diventare ancora più bello di film che
stava loro bellissimo secondo voi
cambierà il colore si o no
che bello per questo permette non so se
funzionerà però vediamo
forse perché attivo non l'abbiamo mai
provato ad aggiungere forma in tanti li
mettono quando sono già attivi pigmenti
nello show live ma soprattutto nei negli
slam trasparenti
ne diamo un po di ogni schieramento
sfumatura sta diventando un po viola
poco poco qui sul lato che
erogabile wow e giocarsi un po tutti che
morbido ma pochi che non è male dai ma
bellissimo al super morbido villino non
mi aspettavo che questi colori mischia
che se mi avrebbero dato questo colore
marrone il back to back mano e marrone
metallizzato bello però mi piace il
viola gita per poco
a costruirli professionista bello mi
piace media allora che è molto da tavola
gissi mi ha spinto molti che vi dico di
questo colore del mio punto vederli da
vicino guardasse un po guardate un po
così vedrete anche il colore bene da
vissino vedete come lucido metallizzato
e si vedono tutti col e inter sono
piccolissimi ridare un volto a questi
mai questi sapere che altri tipi di
video volete vedere ora vi lasciamo fa
quattro cartellini cliccare per vedere i
nostri altri video cliccate su quella
che preferite